FAMER RICK JEANNERET.
>> Rick: AND I DARE YOU BRIAN TO
NAME THE A QUICK TRANSITION HER
LEAGUE.
>> Rick: BEHIND THE NETHEDMAN T.
WIN THAT RACE SO HE WANTED TO
GEK INTO THE CORNER NOW.
AROUND THE BOARDS LEG, LOOKING
PRETTY FANCY GETTING OVER.
AND IT GOES TO ASPLUND AND HE'SN
ACROSS HIS HANDS RIGHT THERE.
EARLIER IN THIS EXCHANGE OFF OF.
BUFFALO GETTING IT A BACK ANDND.
KUCHEROV LETTING IT RIP AND
SUBBAN LOOKED LIKE HEEEES THAT
THROUGH.
AND THAT'S JUST A MATTER RIGHT
THERE OF SUBBANS DOWN
PERRY, CLEARED IN GOTTEN THE
LANE TAKEN AWAY FOR THE PUCK
GETTING TO KUCHEROV ON THTH QUI.
HIS 17 IN OVER THE
THIS I
THE BOARD.
AND NOW DOWN 5-1.
DAHLIN SMOKES IT OFF THE CORNER.
GREAT O O.
SCORES.
THE SHOT FROM KUCHEROV.'S GOT HF
THE NET HERE WITH A TAMPA BAY B.
IN OVER THE LININ OF THE WAY